in the last 12 months the crude oil that
goes into your fuel plastics and
chemical products that has gone up by 79
the natural gas is used for electricity
in your home that's up 60
the copper that's used for your plumbing
and electronics that's up 87
the iron that's used to make steel the
most used metal in the world that's up
128
wheat soybeans cotton sugar and corn
wheat is at 31
soybeans 84 con 44 sugar 55
and corn at a staggering 104 percent and
used cars shot up by nine percent in
april 2021 alone
with lumber taking the crown at a price
hack of 266 percent in the last year
and of course we've been witnessing the
rise in real estate stocks and the rise
and recent crash of crypto for a long
time now
40 percent of us dollars were printed in
the year 2020
and there's been a lot of talks on
whether or not all this new money is
going to cause inflation
and i ultimately think we're gonna see a
real shock
in terms of how high consumer prices are
going to rise
so you think that's how it's going to
end up with all this money printing it's
eventually going to hit consumer prices
well it always does i mean that's like
the final resting place for inflation
is in the end product which is in
consumer goods
well now we're finally starting to feel
it yeah i mean i think the number one
two and three concerns on the market are
inflation
inflation and inflation at this shop
expenses are piling up some supplies
have doubled in price
others have quadrupled the rising cost
of lumber has added an average of 36
thousand dollars to the price of a new
home
coca-cola announced that they would be
rising their prices because everything
they use to make their products is going
up in price
and other huge consumer companies like
png general mills kimberly cluck who
makes a bunch of toilet paper and
personal care products have all
announced similar price hikes
basically welcome to hyperinflation you
look at
every commodity price right new copper
lumber you know make your list
look at what's going on in energy even
before the colonial pipeline issue
look at housing prices look at bitcoin
right everything is inflating the
question is
is this inflation here to stay or are we
witnessing the beginnings of something
much worse
in times like these the ones who suffer
the most are the people with the least
amount of skills
if you're letting people off because
wages are inflating it's a lot easier to
fire the fast food worker than it is to
fire the machine learning expert who
builds your social media algorithms
the problem is learning these skills
that make you unfireable is pretty hard
that's where today's video sponsor comes
in brilliant research has shown that
problem solving is way more effective
than watching lectures
and that's what brilliant does best it
replaces lectures with hands-on
interactive lessons on everything from
probability linear algebra to computer
science and neural networks
it's a better and funner way to learn
all these vital skills for today's
digital economy
and brilliant actually works too take
jacob for example thanks to brilliant's
well-structured math courses
he was able to feel a lot more confident
going into technical job interviews
or this guy who never took advanced math
in school and said that as a self-taught
app developer this is an invaluable tool
join over 9 million people learning on
brilliant right now by pausing the video
and going to brilliant.org
trend to sign up for free and get 20 off
with the link below that's brilliant.com
jake tran with the link below
march 2020 the first lockdown orders
were announced in the us and the money
printer fires up
and almost every business besides
internet businesses slowed down
production with the exception of things
like toilet paper of course
less minerals were mine less lumber was
harvested you get the picture
and along with that came layoffs and a
massive jump in unemployment
april 2020 the money printer really
spins into high gear
going from 5 trillion dollars in
circulation to 16 trillion
in a matter of a month this will stuff
on the 1200
stimulus checks and the other bailouts
that were handed out on top of stimulus
checks from the federal government
individual states also offered extended
unemployment benefits on top of that
throughout the entire year of 2020 and
leading into the start of 2021
other countries offer similar supports
the government hoped that all this money
printing would stimulate the economy
i.e get people to spend money again to
keep the machine rolling but instead of
spending this newly printed money right
away
americans stashed it away or threw it
into things like stocks or crypto
leading to a record savings rate which
brings us to today
the world economy is opening back up
we're on the demand side of the equation
you have a bunch of people that have
been cooped up for over a year begging
to go back to their normal lives with
their normal spending who haven't been
producing as many goods because they're
sitting at home
and they have all this newly printed
money to spend that's driven by
we have kind of a once a moment in
history right you have people
emerging from a pandemic with the animal
spirits that come from being locked
on the supply side you have a
handicapped supply chain with less
production
that's expected to instantly open back
up at 110 capacity
more dollars than ever before chasing
less guests than ever before
or in other words we've made the perfect
storm for inflation
where all you can do is bid up prices
what the government
is doing with all this money printing is
they're artificially
stimulating demand people now have a lot
more money
to go out and buy stuff but people
aren't going into the economy
and producing the stuff so we have all
this money this huge money supply
but there's not goods for people to use
to buy
so all you can do is bid up prices the
government on the one hand
is incentivizing people not to produce
products
and on the other hand they're now
printing up money to give to those
people
who used to be engaged in productive
employment but who are now sitting at
home
in order to receive the money that the
fed just printed
the people empowered the federal reserve
the world bank all unanimously agreed
that this inflation thing is just
temporary
the fancy term they're using is that
it's transitory that there's shortages
in the supply chain and that we just
need to iron out the kinks and
everything will be back to normal
once that happens inflation won't be so
crazy which is true but it's not the
whole picture
see since the only thing that gives the
dollars in our pocket value is the fact
that we believe that it has value
we believe that if i work for my
paycheck today i can use that money to
buy food and a sports car tomorrow
because we believe that we keep working
we keep the economy going
but the moment that trust is broken the
moment that faith is broken
everything falls apart so organizations
like the federal reserve have an
incentive to keep the peace to keep
people from panicking that inflation is
gonna get out of control okay
people move along there's nothing to see
here
remember these are the same people that
told you not to worry about the 2008
financial crisis
these are the same people that said
we're here to stabilize the economy when
in reality the dollar has lost 96
percent of its value probably more than
that by now
since they started their job of
stabilizing the economy in 1913.
[Music]
so in reality this inflation thing might
not be so temporary or transitory
even if this rising in prices is
temporary it doesn't mean prices are
going to go down
see when you increase the amount of
money in circulation by 40
at first it may go into stocks crypto
real estate which would drive out those
prices
but eventually that new money will flow
back into everyday consumer goods that
you and i buy
jacking up prices because we don't buy
stocks or crypto just the half stocks or
crypto
we buy it in hopes of the value going up
so that we can sell and use that money
to buy actual goods we consume later on
like gas food and everything else that's
going up in prices right now
so when you look at it from this angle
is it really that surprising that almost
all the commodities we mentioned at the
beginning of the video all went up in
price by at least 40 percent
around the exact same period that 40 of
us dollars were printed
on top of that when you give someone a
raise because prices are increasing and
they need more money to live
or because they're getting unemployment
benefits that make them not want to work
it's kind of hard to cut people's wages
back in the future
wages are sticky first of all it's hard
to roll back wages once you roll them up
go from 15 to 12. those very generous
extended unemployment benefits are
highly inflationary
so you have fewer goods and services to
buy but more
consumers trying to buy them with more
money
and so that pushes prices way up and if
wages stay at these higher prices
companies will have to make their money
back somewhere which will be from
raising their prices
so once the supply chain does iron out
the kinks to get back to capacity
unless we somehow unprint 40 of the us
dollars out there
the really inflated commodities like
lumber will probably calm down in price
but these higher prices are probably
here to stay now whether or not
inflation will continue to get even
worse is a little harder to answer
but i think a lot of it depends on how
much faith you have that the government
will slow down the money printer
which they have slowed down a little but
they're still printing way faster than
they ever wore pre-kovan
i mean what do you expect the genie has
been let out of the bottle
at the end of the day this is a perfect
illustration of how money printing is
really just a clever way for the
government to tax us
the government wanted to fund some kind
of social program stimulus checks
bailouts
but typically to fund something that
they want to do they have to raise taxes
which is political suicide and then they
collect that money from us on tax day
and then they fund it so we end up with
a social program
but we end up being able to buy less
stuff because we have less money in our
bank account because we paid more in
taxes
in our particular case today they kind
of fund our stimulus checks by taxing us
more because the stimulus checks were
supposed to go to us
so instead they funded the stimulus
checks by printing money in the end we
got the same results we got a new social
program stimulus checks
and we also ended up being able to buy
less stuff the only difference is we're
able to buy less stuff not because we
have less money in our pockets
but because the money in our pocket is
worth less
so let's say you're paying 20 in income
taxes this year whatever the final
inflation number ends up being for this
year
let's say it's the 4.2 percent number
they're touting around
meaning that the value of your cash is
going to go down by 4.2 percent this
year
well the real tax the effective tax rate
you're really paying for 2021 is
actually 24.2
not just 20 if the inflation number ends
up being more like six percent
you'll be paying a 26 income tax 10
inflation you'll be paying nearly a
third of the money you make in taxes
different routes same outcome just less
obvious
[Music]
now you're probably wondering well g
jake how am i gonna protect myself
against this inflation
well in simplest terms if inflation is
say four percent as long as you're
earning at least four percent interest
on your cash you're in the clear
anything above that is just profit
that's where our sponsored block fight
comes in now i'm very careful promoting
financial products on this channel
especially with crypto crashing recently
but i have some of my crypto and block
fi it's backed by industry leading
venture capitalists
and they have a pretty irresistible
offer right now where you can earn up to
10
ap one on all stable coin balances up to
july 31st
meaning that you just create an account
exchange your us dollars for a stable
coin that's pegged to the us dollar on
block fi
and that's literally it you earn up to
10 on that money until july 31st
and if you're still holding bitcoin or
ethereum or you're planning on buying
more by keeping it in block five you can
earn up to five percent apy on bitcoin
and up to four point five percent api on
ethereum
for example i opened up an account just
a few days ago and i've already earned
six dollars doing nothing
pretty cool now of course this is crypto
there's no guarantees these rates can
change in the future and i will only put
in money that you're willing to lose
but i'm keeping my crypto here i wish i
would have started using blackfyre
earlier
and even if these rates change in the
future that's just more of a reason to
take advantage of this right now while
you still can
go to blockfy.com to start earning
interest a day
that's blockfy.com jake with the link
below
[Music]
i hope you guys enjoyed this video today
if you are new here and you want more
business video essays just like this one
we make them every single week
for free for your viewing pleasure so
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and turn on the notification bell too
that's gonna wrap it up we're gonna keep
this one short so thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you